okay hello everyone okay we should get
started
there actually are still quite a few
seats left if you want to be really bold
a couple of seats right in front of me
in the front row if you're less bold or
a few over there but you know also on
some of the roads are quite a few middle
seats so if people wanted to be really
civic minded some people could sort of
squeeze towards the edges and make more
accessible some of the seats that still
exist in the classroom okay so you know
it's really exciting and great to see so
many people here so I'm a hearty welcome
to CS 224 in occasionally also known as
Ling 284 which is natural language
processing with deep learning has just a
sort of a personal anecdote it still
sort of blows my mind that so many
people turn up to this class these days
so for about the first decade that I
taught NLP here you know the number of
people I got each year was approximately
45 so it's an order of magnitude smaller
than it is now which I guess says quite
a lot on about what a revolutionary
impact their artificial intelligence in
general and machine learning deep
learning NLP are starting to have in
modern society okay
so this is our plan for today so I mean
we're really going to get straight down
to business today so there'll be a brief
very brief introduction some of the sort
of course logistics very brief
discussion and talk about human language
and word meaning and then we want to get
right into talking about the first thing
that we're doing which is coming up with
word vectors and looking at the word
Davich algorithm and that'll then sort
of fill up the rest of the class there
are still two seats right in the front
row for someone who wants to sit right
in front of me just letting you know
okay okay so here the course logistics
in brief so I'm Christopher Manning the
person who bravely became the head ta is
ABC who's right there and then we have
quite a lot of wonderful
TAS to the people who are wonderful TAS
just want to stand up for one moment so
we have some sense of wonderful TAS okay
great
okay so you know when the lecture is
because you made it here and so welcome
also to SCPD people this is also in a
CPD class and you can watch it on video
but we love for Stanford students to
turn up and show their beautiful faces
in the classroom okay so the webpage has
all the info about syllabus etc etc okay
so this class what do we hope to teach
so one thing that we want to teach is
you know an understanding of effective
modern methods for deep learning
starting off by reviewing some of the
basics and then particularly
talking about the kinds of techniques
including recurrent networks and
attention that are widely used for
natural language processing models the
second thing we want to teach is a big
picture understanding of human languages
and some of the different ease and
understanding and producing them of
course if you want to know a lot about
human languages there's a whole
linguistics department you can do a lot
of courses of that but so I want to give
at least some appreciation so you have
some clue of what are the challenges and
difficulties and varieties of human
languages and then this is also kind of
a practical class like we actually want
to teach you how you can build practical
systems that work for some of the major
parts of NLP so if you go and get a job
at one of those tech firms and they say
hey could you build us a named entity
recognizer you can say sure I can do
that and so for a bunch of problems
obviously we can't do everything we're
going to do word meaning dependency
parsing machine translation and you have
an option to do question answering
actually building systems for those if
you've been talking to friends who did
the class in the last couple of years
here are the differences for this year
just to get things straight so we've
updated some of the content of the
course so between me and guest lectures
there's new content what that look bad I
wonder if that will keep happening we'll
find out
there's new content on various topics
that are sort of developing areas one of
the problems with this course is really
the area of deep learning at the moment
is still just developing really really
quickly so it sort of seems like
one-year old content it's already kinks
kind of data than we're trying to update
things a big change that we're making
this year is we're having five one-week
assignments instead of three two-week
assignments at the beginning of the
course and I'll say a bit more about
that in a minute this year we're going
to use PI torch instead of tensorflow
and we can talk about that more later -
we're having the assignments due before
class on either Tuesday or Thursday so
you're not distracted and can come to
class so starting off yeah so we're
trying to give an easier gentler ramp up
but on the other hand a fast ramp up so
we've got this first assignment which is
sort of easy but it's available right
now and is due next Tuesday and the
final thing is we're not having a
midterm this year okay so this is what
we're doing so there are five of these
assignments that I just mentioned so six
percent for the first one 12 percent for
each of the other ones and I've always
said that we're going to use grade scope
for grading it's been really help out
the TAS if you could use your su net ID
as your grade scope account ID so then
for the second part of the course people
do a final project and there are two
choices for the final project you can
either do our default final project
which is a good option for many people
or you can do a custom final project now
I'll talk about that in a more in the
beginning and this is not working right
and so then at the end we have a final
poster presentation session at which
your attendance is expected and we're
going to be having that Wednesday in the
evening probably not quite five hours
but it'll be within that window we'll
work out the details in a bit three
percent for participation see the
website for details six late day's
collab
operation like always in computer
science classes we want you to do your
own work and not borrow stuff from other
people's github x' and so we really do
emphasize that you should read and pay
attention to collaboration policies okay
so here's the high-level plan for the
problem sets
so homework 1 available right now is a
hopefully easy on-ramp there's an I
Python notebook just help get everyone
up to speed
homework 2 is pure Python plus numpy but
that will start to kind of teach you
more about the sort of underlying how do
we do deep learning if you are not so
good or a bit rusty or never seen Python
or numpy we're going to have an extra
section on Friday so Friday from 1:30 to
2:50 in skilling auditorium we'll have a
section that's a Python review that's
our only planned section at the moment
we're not gonna have a regular section
so encourage to go to that and that will
also be recorded for SCPD and available
for video as well
then homework 3 will start us on using
PI torch and then homeworks 4 and 5
we're then going to be using pi PI torch
on GPU and we're actually going to be
using Microsoft Azure with big thank
yous to the kind Microsoft Azure people
who have sponsored our GPU computing for
the last three years yes so basically I
mean all of modern deep learning has
moved to the use of one or other of the
large deep learning libraries like pi
torched in supply chain or MX net etc
and then doing the computing on GPU so
of course since we're in the wrong
building we should of course be using
GPUs but I mean in general the sort of
parallelism scalability of GPUs is
what's powered most of modern deep
learning ok the final project so for the
final project there are two things that
you can do so we have a default final
project which is essentially our final
project
box and so this is building a question
answering system and we do it over the
squad Deva said so what you build and
how you can improve your performance is
completely up to you it is open-ended
but it has an easier start a clearly
defined objective and we can have a
leaderboard for how well things are
working so if you don't have a clear
research objective that can be a good
choice for you or you can propose a
custom final project and presuming it's
sensible will approve your custom final
project we will give you feedback format
someone as a mentor and either way for
only the final project we allow teams of
one two or three but the homeworks
you're expected to do them yourself
though of course you can chat to people
in a general way about the problems okay
so that is the course all good
I'm not even behind schedule yet okay so
the next section is human language and
word meaning you know if I was really
going to tell you a lot about human
language that would take a lot of time
which I don't really have here so I'm
just going to tell you two anecdotes
about human language and the first is
this xkcd cartoon and I mean this isn't
not sure what make that so I actually
really like this xkcd cartoon it's not
one of the classic ones that you see
most often around the place but I
actually think it says a lot about
language and is worth thinking about
like I think a lot of the time for the
kind of people who come to this class
who are mainly people like CS people and
people and random others there are some
other people I know since these people
linguists and so on around but for a lot
of those people like you've sort of
spent your life looking at formal
languages and the impression is that
sort of human languages are sort of
somehow a little bit broken formal
languages and there's really a lot more
to it than that right that languages is
amazing human created sis
that is used for all sorts of purposes
and is adaptable to all sorts of
purposes so you can do everything from
describing mathematics and human
language to sort of nuzzling up to your
best friend and getting them to
understand you better so there's
actually an amazing thing at human
language anyway I'll just read it so
it's the first person the dark-haired
person says anyway I could care less and
her friend says I think you mean you
couldn't care less saying you could care
less implies you care at least some
amount and the dark-haired person says I
don't know we're these unbelievably
complicated brain's drifting through a
void trying in vain to connect with one
another by blindly fleeing words out
into the darkness every choice of
phrasing and spelling and tone and
timing carries countless signals and
contexts and subtext and more and every
listener interprets those signals in
their own way languages in the formal
system language is glorious chaos you
can never know for sure what any words
will mean to anyone all you can do is
try to get better at guessing how your
words affect people so you can have a
chance of finding the ones that will
make them feel something like what you
want them to feel everything else is
pointless
I assume you're giving me tips on how
you interpret words because you want me
to feel less alone if so thank you that
means a lot but if you're just running
my sentences past some mental checklist
so you can show off how well you know it
then I could care less and so I think
I think actually this has some nice
messages about how languages this
uncertain evolved system of
communication but somehow we have enough
agreed meaning that you know we can kind
of pretty much communicate but we're
doing some kind of your probabilistic
inference of guessing what people mean
and we're using language not just for
the information functions but the social
functions etc etc okay and then here's
my one other thought I'd give you about
language so essentially if we want to
have artificial intelligence that's
intelligent what we need to somehow get
to the point of having computers that
have the knowledge of human beings right
because human beings have knowledge that
gives them intelligence and if you think
about how we sort of convey knowledge
around the place in our human world
mainly the way we do it is through human
language you know some kinds of
knowledge you can sort of work out for
yourself by doing physical stuff right I
can hold this and drop it and I've
learned something so I've learned a bit
of knowledge there but sort of most of
the knowledge in your heads and why
you're sitting in this classroom has
come from people communicating in human
language to you so one of the famous
most famous deep learning people yan
Laocoon he likes to say this line about
oh you know really I think that you know
there's not much difference between the
intelligence of a human being and
orangutan and I actually think he's
really wrong on that like the sense in
which he means it is an orangutan has a
really good vision system orangutangs
have very good you know control of their
arms just like human beings for picking
things up orangutangs can use tools and
orangutangs can make plans so that if
you sort of put the food somewhere where
they have to sort of move the plank to
get to the island with the food they can
do a plan like that so yeah in a sense
they've got a fair bit of intelligence
but you know sort of orangutangs just
aren't like human beings and why aren't
they lie
human beings and I'd like to suggest you
the reason for that is what human beings
have achieved is we don't just have sort
of one computer like a you know a dusty
old IBM PC in your mother's garage what
we have is a human computer network and
the way that we've achieved our human
computer network is that we use human
languages as our networking language and
so when you think about it so on any
kind of evolutionary scale languages
super super super super recent right
that creatures have had vision for
people don't quite know but you know
maybe it's 75 million years or maybe
it's longer I'd a huge length of time
how long have human beings have had
language you know people don't know that
either because it turns out you know
when you have fossils you can't knock
the skull on the side and say do you
know have language but you know most
people estimate that sort of language is
a very recent invention before current
human beings moved out of out of Africa
so that many people think that we've
only had language for something like a
hundred thousand years or something like
that so it's sort of you know blink of
an eye on the evolutionary timescale but
you know it was the development of
language I'd assert that sort of made
human beings invisible in invincible
right it wasn't that human beings
developed poison fangs or developed the
ability to run faster than any other
creature or put a big horn on their
heads or something like that right you
know humans are basically pretty puny
but they had this unbeatable advantage
that they could communicate with each
other and therefore work much more
effectively in teams and that sort of
basically made human beings invincible
but you know even then humans were kind
of limited right that kind of got you to
about the Stone Age right where you
could bang on your stones and with the
right kind of stone make something sharp
to cut with what God humans beyond that
was that they invented writing
writing was then an ability where you
could take knowledge and not only
communicate it yeah mouth to mouth to
people that you saw you could put it
down on your piece of papyrus or your
clay tablet or whatever it was at first
and that knowledge could then be sent
places it could be sent spatially around
the world and it could then be sent
temporally through time and well how old
is writing I mean we sort of basically
know about how old writing is right that
writing is about 5,000 years old right
right it's incredibly incredibly recent
on this scale of evolution but you know
essentially writing was so powerful as a
way of having knowledge that then in
those 5,000 years that Abel enabled
human beings to go from Stone Age sharp
piece of Flint to you know having
iPhones and all of these things there's
incredibly sophisticated devices so
language is pretty special thing I'd
like to suggest but you know if I go
back to my analogy that sort of it's
allowed humans to construct a networked
computer that is way way more powerful
than just having individual creatures as
sort of intelligent like an orangutan
and you compare it to our computer
networks it's a really funny kind of
network right you know that these days
we have networks that run around where
we have sort of large network bandwidth
right you know we might be frustrated
sometimes with our Netflix downloads but
by and large you know we can download
hundreds of megabytes really easily and
quickly and we don't think that's fast
enough so we're going to be rolling out
5g network so it's an order of magnitude
faster again I mean by comparison to
that I mean human language is a
pathetically slow Network right that the
amount of information you can convey by
human language is very slow I mean you
know whatever it is I sort of speak at
about 15 words a second right you can
start doing your information theory if
you know something right but you don't
actually get much bandwidth the tall and
then leads so you can think of how does
it work then so humans have come up with
this incredibly impressive system which
is essentially a form of compression
it's sort of a very adaptive form of
compression so that when we're talking
to people we assume that they have an
enormous amount of knowledge in their
heads which isn't the same as but it's
broadly similar to mine when I'm talking
to you right that you know what English
words mean and you know a lot about how
the word world works and therefore I can
say a short message and communicate only
a relatively short bit string and you
can actually understand a lot right so I
can say sort of whatever you know
imagine a busy shopping mall and that
there are two guys standing in front of
a makeup counter and you know I've only
said whatever that was sort of about 200
bits of information but that's enabled
you to construct a whole visual scene
that were taking megabytes to represent
as an image so that's why language is
good so from that more ethereal level
I'll now move back to the concrete stuff
and what we want to do in this class is
not solve the whole of language but we
want to represent the meaning of words
right so a lot of language is bound up
in words and their meanings and words
can have really rich meanings right as
soon as you say it word teacher that's
kind of got a lot of rich meaning or you
can have actions that have rich meaning
so if I say a word like prognostic aid
or dawdle or something you know these
words and have rich meanings and a lot
of nuance on them and so we want to
represent meaning and so the question is
what is meaning so you can of course you
can dictionaries are meant to tell you
about meaning so you can look up
dictionaries and Webster says sort of
tries to relate meaning to idea the idea
that is represented by a word or a
phrase the idea that a person wants to
express by word signs etc I mean you
know you could think that these
definitions are kind of a cop-out
because it seems like they're rewriting
meaning in terms of the word idea and
has that really gone new anywhere
how do linguists think about meaning I
mean the most common way that linguists
have thought about meaning is an idea
that's called denotational semantics
which is also used in programming
languages so the idea of that is we
think of meaning as what things
represent so if I say the word chair the
denotation of the word chair includes
this one here and that one that one that
one that one and so the word chair is
sort of representing all the things that
are chairs and you can sort of you could
then think of something like running as
well that you know there's sort of sets
of actions that people can just partake
that that's their denotation and that's
sort of what you most commonly see in
philosophy or linguistics as denotation
it's kind of a hard thing to get your
hands on computationally so and what do
people most commonly do or use the most
commonly do I guess I should say now for
working out the meaning of words and the
computer they're commonly they're turn
to something there was a bit like a
dictionary in particular favorite online
thing was this online thesaurus called
wordnet which sort of tells you about
word meanings and relationships between
word meanings so this is just giving you
the very slice of sense of of what's in
word net so this is an actual bit of
Python code up there which you can type
into your computer and run and do this
for yourself so this uses a thing called
NLT K so in all TK is sort of like the
Swiss Army knife of NLP meaning that
it's not terribly good for anything but
it has a lot of basic tools and so if
you want to do something like just get
some stuff out of wordnet and show it
it's the perfect thing to use okay so
I'm from in otk I'm importing wordnet
and so then I can say okay for the word
good tell me about the synonym sets the
good participates in and there's good
goodness as a now there's an adjective
good there's one estimable good
honorable respectable and
this looks really complex and hard to
understand but the idea of word wording
that makes these very fine-grained
distinctions between senses of a word so
we're sort of saying for good there's
what some senses where it's a noun right
that's where you sort of I bought some
goods for my trip right so that's sort
of one of these noun sensors like this
one I guess
then there are adjective sensors and
it's trying to distinguish there's a
basic adjective sense of good being good
and then in certain senses there are
these extended senses of good in
different directions so I guess this is
good in the sense of beneficial and this
one is sort of person who was
respectable or something he's a good man
or something like that right so but you
know part of what's kind of makes this
thing very problematic and practice to
use as it tries to make all these very
fine-grain differences between sensors
that are a human being can barely
understand the difference between them
and relate to so you can then do other
things with wordnet so at this bit of
code you can sort of work walk up and is
a kind of hierarchy so it's kind of like
a traditional database so if I start
with a panda and say I'm going to start
with a panda and walk up that pandas are
Tokyo needs maybe you'd guys did bio
which are carnivores potentials mammal
block okay so that's the kind of stuff
you can get out of wordnet you know in
practice word nedeth mean everyone sort
of used to use it because it gave you
some sort of sense of the meaning of the
word but you know it's also sort of well
known it never worked that well so you
know that it's sort of the synonym sets
miss a lot of nuance so you know one of
the synonym sets for good has proficient
in it and good sort of like proficient
but doesn't proficient have some more
connotations and nuance I think it does
word net like most hand-built resources
is sort of very incomplete so as soon as
you're coming to new meanings of words
or new
birds and slang words wordnet gives you
nothing it's sort of built with human
labor in ways that you know it's hard to
sort of create and adapt and in
particular what we want to focus on is
seems like a basic thing you'd like to
do with words is actually at least
understand similarities and relations
between the meaning of words and it
turns out that you know wordnet doesn't
actually do that that well because it
just has these sort of fixed discreet
synonym set so if you have a words in a
synonym set that there's sort of a
synonym but maybe not exactly the same
meaning if they're not on the same
synonym said you kind of can't really
measure the partial resemblances of
meaning for them so something like good
and marvelous aren't in the same synonym
said but there's something that they
share in common that you'd like to
represent okay so that's kind of going
to lead into us wanting to do something
different and better forward meaning and
before getting there I just sort of want
to again sort of build a little from
traditional NLP so traditional NLP in
the context of this course sort of means
natural language processing up until
approximately 2012 there were some
earlier antecedents but as basically in
2013 that things really began to change
with people starting to use neural net
style representations for natural
language processing so up until 2012
standardly you know we had words they're
just words so we had hotel conference
motel there were words and we'd have neo
lexicons and put words into our model
and in your networks land this is
referred to as a localist representation
I'll come back to those terms again next
time but that's sort of meaning that for
any concept there's sort of one
particular place which is the word Hotel
or the word Motel a way of thinking
about that is to think about what
happens when you build a machine
learning model so if you have a
categorical variable like you have words
with the choice of word and you want to
stick there
into some kind of classifier in a
machine learning model somehow you have
to code that categorical variable and
the standard way of doing it is that you
code it by having different levels of
the variable which means that you have a
vector and you have this is the word
house this is the word cat this is the
word dog this is the word some just this
is the word agreeable this is the word
something else this is the word hotel
and this is the another word for
something different right so that you
have put a one at the position and in
your net land we call these one hot
vectors and so these might be our one
hot vectors for hotel and motel so there
are a couple of things that are bad here
the one that's sort of a practical
nuisance is you know languages have a
lot of words right so one of those
dictionaries that you might have still
had in school they probably have about
250,000 words in them but you know if
you start getting to more technical and
scientific English it's easy to get to a
million words I mean actually the number
of words that you have in a language
like English it's actually infinite
because we have these processes which
are called derivational morphology where
you can make more words by adding
endings on to existing words so you know
you can start with something like
paternal as fatherly and then you can
sort of say from paternal you can say
paternalist or paternalistic or
paternalism and put I did it
paternalistically right there all these
ways that you can make bigger words by
adding more stuff into it and so really
you end up with an infinite space of
words yeah so that's a minor problem
right we have very big vectors if we
want to represent a sensible sized
vocabulary but there's a much bigger
problem than that which is well
precisely what we want to do all the
time is we want to sort of understand
relationships in the meaning of words so
you know an obvious example of this is
web search so if I do a search for
Seattle motel it'd be useful if it also
showed me results that had Seattle hotel
all on the page and vice versa because
you know hotel and motels pretty much
the same thing but you know if we have
these one hot vectors like we had before
they have no similarity relationship
between them right so in math terms
these two vectors are orthogonal no
similarity relationship between them and
so you kind of get nowhere now there are
things that you could do hey I just
showed you would and wouldn't it shows
you some synonyms and stuff so that
might help a bit there are other things
you could do you could sort of say well
wait why don't we just build up a big
table where we have a big table of words
similarities and we could work with that
and you know people used to try and do
that right you know that's sort of what
Google did in 2005 or something you know
it had word similarity tables the
problem with doing that is you know we
were talking about how maybe we want
five hundred thousand words and if you
want to build up then a word similarity
table out of pairs of words from one hot
representations you that means that the
size of that table as my math is pretty
bad is that two and a half trillion it's
some very big number ourselves in your
similarity matrix so that's almost
impossible to do so what we're going to
instead do is explore a method in which
we're going to represent words as
vectors in a way I'll show you just a a
minute in such a way that just the
representation of a word gives you their
similarity with no further work okay and
so that's going to lead into these
different ideas so I mentioned before
denotational semantics here's another
idea for representing the meaning of
words which is called distributional
semantics and so the idea of
distributional semantics is well how
we're going to represent the meaning of
a word is by looking at the contexts in
which it appears so this is a picture of
Jr who as a British linguist and he's
famous for this saying you shall know a
word by the company it keeps but another
person who's very famous for
developing this notion of meaning is the
philosopher love did with bid constant
and his later writings which he referred
to as a use theory of meeting meaning
actually he's used some big German word
that I don't know but we'll call it a
use theory of meaning and you know
essentially the point was well you know
if you can explain every if if you can
explain what context it's correct to use
a certain word versus in what context
would be the wrong word to use this
maybe gives you bad memories of doing
English in high school and people said
how that's wrong word to use there well
then you understand the meaning of the
word right and so that's the idea of
distributional semantics and it's been
one of the most successful ideas in one
statistical NLP because it gives you a
great way to learn about word meaning
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to say how one low at the word
banking means so I'm going to grab a lot
of text which is easy to do now when we
have the World Wide Web
I'll find lots of sentences where the
word banking is use government debt
problems turning into banking crises has
happened in 2009 and look these I'm just
going to say all of this stuff is the
meaning of the word banking that those
are the contexts in which the word
banking is used and that seems it very
simple and perhaps even not quite right
idea but it turns out to be a very
usable idea that does a great job at
capturing meaning and so what we're
going to do is say rather than our old
localist representation we're now going
to represent words in what we call a
distributed representation and so for
the distributed representation we're
still going to represent the meaning of
a word as a numeric vector but now we're
going to say that the meaning of each
word is a small wish vector but it's
going to be a dense victor whereby all
of the numbers are nonzero so the
meaning of banking is going to be
distributed over the dimensions of this
vector now my vector here is of
dimension 9 because I want to keep the
slot
nice life isn't quite that good in
practice when we do this we use a larger
dimensionality kind of sort of the
minimum that people use is 50 a typical
number that you might use on your laptop
is 300 if you want to really max out
performance
maybe thousand two thousand four
thousand but you know nevertheless
orders of magnitude smaller compared to
a length five hundred thousand vector
okay so we have words with their vector
representations and so since each word
is going to have a vector representation
we then have a vector space in which we
can place all of the words and that's
completely unreadable but if you zoom in
to the vector space it's still
a bit further you can find different
parts of this space so here's the part
that where countries are tending to
exist Japanese German French Russian and
British Australian American France
Britain Germany etc and you can shift
over to a different part of the space so
here's part of a space where various
verbs are so has have had been beings
remain be are is was where you can even
see the salm morphological forms are
grouping together and things that sort
of go together like say think expect the
things that take those kind of
complement he said or thought something
they group together now what am I
actually showing you here
you know really this was built from 100
dimensional word vectors and there's
this problem it's really hard to
visualize 100 dimensional word vectors
so what is actually happening here is
these 100 dimensional word vectors are
being projected down into two dimensions
and you're showing seeing a
two-dimensional view which I'll get back
to later so on the one hand whenever you
see these pictures you should hold onto
your wallet because there's a huge
amount of detail in the original vector
space that got completely killed and
went away
in the 2d projection and indeed some of
what push things together in the 2d
projection may really merely
really misrepresent what's in the
original space but even looking at these
2d representations the overall feeling
is by gosh this actually sort of works
doesn't that we can sort of see
similarities between words okay so yeah
so that was the idea of what we want to
do the next part is then how do we
actually go about doing it I will pause
for breath per half a minute
has anyone got a question they're dying
to ask they're not standing across NLP
and they're not chosen at all so what
we're going to present is a learning
algorithm so where we just sort of
shovel in lots of text and miraculously
these word vectors come out and so the
learning algorithm itself decides the
dimensions but that actually reminds me
of something I sort of meant to say
which was yeah I mean since this is a
vector space in some sense the
dimensions of it are arbitrary right
because you can you know just have your
basis vectors in any different direction
and you could sort of rear nth the words
and the vector space with a different
set of basics basis vectors and it'd be
exactly the same vector space just sort
of rotate around your new vectors so you
know you shouldn't read too much into
the sort of elements though it actually
turns out that because of the way a lot
of deep learning operations work some
things they do do element wise so that
the dimensions do actually tend to get
some meaning to them it turns out but
the thing I really want
to say was that you know one thing we
can just think of is how close things
are in the vector space and that's a
notion of meaning similarity that we're
going to exploit but you might hope that
you get more than that you might
actually think that there's meaning in
different dimensions and directions and
the word vector space and the answer
that there is there is and I'll come
back to that a bit later
okay so in some sense the thing that had
the biggest impact in sort of turning
the world of NLP in a neural networks
direction was that picture was this
algorithm that tamashii me Koloff came
up with in 2013 called the word - Beck
algorithm so it wasn't the first work
and having distributed representations
of words so there was older work from
yoshua bengio that went back to about
the sort of turn on the millennium but
somehow it sort of hadn't really sort of
hit the world over the head and had a
huge impact and I was really sort of
tomash McAuliffe showed this very simple
very scalable way of learning vector
representations of words and that sort
of really opened the floodgates and so
that's the algorithm that I'm gonna show
now okay so the idea of this algorithm
is you start with a big pile of text so
whatever you find you know webpages on
newspaper articles something a lot of
continuous text right actual sentences
because we want to learn with word
meaning context um NLP people call a
large pile of text a corpus and I mean
that's just the Latin word for body
right it's a body of text important
things know if you want to seem really
educated is in Latin this is a fourth
declension noun so the plural of corpus
is corpora and whereas if you say core
PI everyone will know that you didn't
study that in the high school
okay so right so we then want to say
that every word in the in a fixed
vocabulary which would just be the
vocabulary the corpus is represented by
a vector and we just start those vectors
off as random vectors and so then what
we're going to do is do this a big
iterative algorithm where we go through
each position in the text we say here's
a word in the text let's look at the
words around that and what we're going
to want to do is say well the meaning of
a word is this context of use so we want
the representation of the word in the
middle to be able to predict the words
that are around that and so we're going
to achieve that by moving the position
of the word vector and we just repeat
that a billion times and somehow a
miracle occurs and out comes at the end
we have a word vector space that looks
like a picture I showed where it has a
good meaning of word meet a good
representation of word meaning so
slightly more is slightly more
graphically right so here's the
situation so we've got part of our
corpus problems turning into banking
crises and so what we want to say is
well we want to know the meaning of the
word into and so we're going to hope
that it's representation can be used in
the way that I'll make precise to
predict what words appear in the context
of into because that's the meaning of
into and so we're going to try and make
those predictions see how well we can
predict and then change the vector
representation of words in a way that we
can do that prediction better and then
once we've dealt with into we just go on
to the next word and we say okay let's
take banking as the word the meaning of
banking is predicting the context and
which banking occurs here's one context
let's try and predict these words that
occur around banking and see how we do
and then we'll move on again from there
okay
sounds easy so far now we go on and sort
of do a bit more stuff okay so overall
we have a big long
of capital T word so if we have a whole
lot of documents we just concatenate
them all together and we say okay here's
a billion words as a big long list of
words and so what we're going to do is
for the first product we're going to
sort of go through all the words and
then for the second product we're going
to say we're going to choose some fixed
size window you know it might be five
words on each side or something and
we're going to try and predict the ten
words that are around our Center word
and we're going to predict in the sense
of trying to predict that word given the
Center word that's our probability model
and so if we multiply all those things
together that's our model likelihood is
how good a job it does at predicting the
words around every word and that model
likelihood is going to depend on the
parameters of our model which we write
as theta and in this particular model
the only parameters inert is actually
going to be the vector representations
we give two words the model has
absolutely no other parameters to it so
we're just going to say we are
representing a word with a vector in a
vector space and that representation of
it is this meaning and we're then going
to be able to use that to predict what
other words occur in a way I'm about to
show you okay so that's our likelihood
and so what we do in all of these models
is we sort of define an objective
function and then we're going to be I
want to come up with vector
representations of words in such a way
as to minimize our objective function
so our objective function is basically
the same as what's on the top half of
the slide but we change a couple of
things we stick a minus sign in front of
it so we can do minimization rather than
maximization completely arbitrary makes
no difference we stick a 1 and T in
front of it so that we're working out
the sort of average as ever goodness of
predicting for each choice of sent a
word again that sort of makes no
difference but it kind of keeps the
scale of things not dependent on the
size of the corpus the bit
it's actually important is we stick a
log in front of the function that was up
there because it turns out that
everything always gets nice and when you
stick logs in front of products and when
you're doing things like optimization so
when we do that we've then got a log of
all these products which will allow us
to turn things in or into a sums of the
log of this probability and we'll go
through that again in just a minute okay
and so if we can MIT if we can change
our vector representations of these
words so as to minimize this J of theta
that means we'll be good at predicting
words in the context of another word so
then that all sounded good but it was
all dependent on having this probability
function where you want to predict the
probability of a word in the context
given the Center word and the question
is how can you possibly do that
well remember what I said is actually
our model is just going to have vector
representations of words and that was
the only parameters of the model now
that's that's almost true it's not quite
true
we actually cheat slightly since we
actually propose to vector
representations for each word and this
makes it simpler to do this you cannot
do this there are ways to get around
that but this is the simplest way to do
it so we have one vector for a word when
it's the Center word it's predicting
other words but we have a second vector
for each word when it's a context word
so that's one of the words and context
so for each word type we have these two
vectors as sent a word as context word
so then we're going to work out this
probability of a word in the context
given a Center word purely in terms of
these vectors and the way we do it is
with this equation right here which I'll
explain more in just a moment so we're
still on exactly the same situation
right that we're wanting to work out
probabilities of words occurring the
context of our Center word so the center
word is C and
takes words represented with oh and
these some of this slide notation but
sort of we're basically saying there's
one kind of vector for Center words
there's a different kind of vector for
context words and we're going to work
out this probabilistic prediction in
terms of these word vectors okay so how
can we do that well the way we do it is
with this formula here which is a sort
of shape that you see over and over
again and deep learning with categorical
stuff so for the very center bit of at
the bit in orange more the same thing
occurs in the denominator what we're
doing there is calculating a dot product
so we're going to go through the
components of our vector and we're going
to multiply them together and that means
if different words have big components
of the same sign plus or minus in the
same positions the dot product will be
big and if they have different signs or
ones big and one small the dot product
will be a lot smaller so that orange
part directly calculates sort of a
similarity between words where the
similarity is there sort of vectors
looking the same right and so that's the
heart of it right so we're going to have
words that have similar vectors is close
together in the vector space have
similar meaning so for the rest of it
so the next thing we do is take that
number and put an x parameter so the
exponential has this nice property that
no matter what number you stick into it
because the dot product might be
positive or negative it's going to come
out as a positive number and if we
eventually want to get a probability
that's really good if we have positive
numbers and not negative numbers so
that's good then the third part of it
which is the bit in blue is we wanted to
have probabilities and probabilities are
meant to add up to one and so we do that
in the standard dumbest possible way we
sum up what this quantity is that every
different word in our vocabulary and we
divide through by it and so that
normalizes things and
them into a probability distribution
yeah so there's sort of in practice
there are two parts there's the orange
part which is this idea of using dot
product in a vector space as our
similarity measure between words and
then the second part is all the rest of
it where we feed it through what we
refer to and use all the time as a
softmax distribution so the two parts of
the x bone
normalizing gives you a soft max
distribution and soft next functions
will sort of map any numbers into a
probability distribution always for the
two reasons that I gave and so it's
referred to as a soft max because it
works like a soft max right so if you
have numbers you could just say what's
the max of these numbers and you know
that's sort of a heart if you sort of
map your original numbers into if it's
the max of the max and everything else
is 0 that's sort of hard max soft but
this is a soft max because the
exponential you know if you sort of
imagine this but if we just ignore the
problem negative numbers for a moment
and you got rid of the X then you'd sort
of been coming out with a probability
distribution but by-and-large is so be
fairly flat and wouldn't particularly
pick out the max of the different xim
burs whereas when you exponentiate them
that sort of makes big numbers way
bigger and so this the softmax sort of
mainly puts mass where the max is or the
couple of maxes are so that's the max
part and the soft part is that this
isn't a hard decision still spreads a
little bit of probability mass
everywhere else okay so now we have a
loss function we have a loss function
with a probability model on the inside
that we can build and so what we want to
be able to do is then move our vector
representations of words around so that
they are good at predicting what words
occur in the context of other words and
so
at this point what we're going to do is
optimization so we have vector
components of different words we have a
very high dimensional space again but
you know I've just got to for the
picture and we're going to want to say
how can we minimize this function and
we're going to want a jiggle the numbers
that are used in the word
representations in such a way that we're
walking down the slope of this space I
walking down the gradient and then we're
going to minimize the function and we
found good representations for words so
doing this for this case we want to make
a very big Bek de in a very high
dimensional vector space of all the
parameters of our model and the only
parameters that this model has is
literally the vector space
representations of words so if they're
hundred dimensional word representations
they're sort of a hundred parameters for
aardvark in context 100 parameters for
the word art in context etc going
through 100 parameters for the word
aardvark is a center word etc etc
through that gives us a high big vector
of parameters to optimize and we're
going to run this optimization and then
move them down yeah so that's
essentially what you do I sort of wanted
to go through the details of this just
so we've kind of gone through things
concretely to make sure everyone is on
the same page so I suspect that you know
if I try and do this
concretely there are a lot of people
that this will bore and some people that
are will bore very badly so I'll
apologize for you but you know I'm
hoping and thinking that there are
probably some people who haven't done as
much of this stuff recently and it might
just actually be good to do it
concretely and get everyone up to speed
right at the beginning yeah
that you eat specifically well so we're
so the way we calculate the U and V
vectors is we're literally going to
start with a random vector for each word
and then we eat reveille going to change
those vectors a little bit as we learn
and the way we're going to work out how
to change them is we're going to say I
want to do optimization and that is
going to be implemented as okay we have
the current vectors for each word let me
do some calculus to work out how I could
change the word vectors to mean that the
word vectors would calculate a higher
probability for the words that actually
occur in context of this Center word and
we will do that and we'll do it again
and again and again and then we'll
eventually end up with good word vectors
thank you for that question because
that's the concept that you're meant to
have understood how this works and maybe
I didn't explain that high level recipe
well enough
yeah okay so yeah so let's just go
through it so we've seen it right so we
had this formula that we wanted to
maximize you know original function
which was the product of T equals 1 to T
and then the product of the words
position of minus M where equal to j
less than or equal to m j not equal to
zero of the probability of W Prime at T
plus J given WT according to the
parameters of our model okay and then
we'd already seen that we were going to
convert that into the function that we
were going to use where we have J of
theta where we had the minus 1 on T of
the sum of T equals 1 to T of the sum of
minus M with new trilogy
zero of the log of the probability w nu
t + j WT okay so we had that and then we
had had this formula that the
probability of the outside word given
the context word is this formula we just
went through of x uo t vc over the sum
of W equals 1 to the vocab you size of X
u WT C okay so that's sort of our model
we want 2 min if I minimize this so we
want to minimize this and we want to
minimize that by changing these Pat
parameters and these parameters are the
contents of these vectors and so what we
want to do now is do calculus and we
want to say let's work out in terms of
these parameters which are our U and V
vectors for the current values of the
parameters between Ischl eyes randomly
like what's the slope of the space where
is downhill because where we can work
out downhill is we got just going to
walk downhill and our model get better
so we're going to take derivatives and
work out what direction downhill is and
then we want to walk that way yeah I'm
wanting to achieve this what I want to
achieve for my distributional notion of
meaning is I have a meaningful word a
vector and that vector knows what words
occur in the context of were of itself
and knowing what words occur in its
context means it can accurately give a
high probability estimate to those words
that occur in the context and it will
give low probability
estimates to words that don't typically
occur in the context so you know if the
word is Bank I'm hoping that words like
branch and open and withdrawal will be
given high probability because they tend
to occur with the word bank and I'm
hoping that some other words like neural
network or something have a lower
probability because they don't tend to
occur with the word Bank okay does that
make sense
yeah and the other thing I was we've got
meant to comment was you know obviously
we're not going to be able to do this
super well or I it's just not going to
be able that we can say all the world in
the context is going to be this word
with probability 0.97 right because
we're using this one simple probability
distribution to predict all words in our
context so in particular we're using it
to predict ten different words generally
right so at best we can kind of be
giving sort of 5% chance to one of them
right we can't possibly be so guessing
right every time and well you know
they're going to be different context
with different words in them so you know
it's gonna be a very loose model but
nevertheless we want to capture the fact
that you know withdrawal is much more
likely to occur near the word Bank then
something like football that's you know
basically what our goal is okay yes so
we want to maximize this by minimizing
this which means we then want to do some
calculus to work this out so what we're
then going to do is that we're going to
say well these parameters are our word
vectors and we're going to sort of want
to move these word vectors to work
things out as to how to walk downhill so
the case that I'm going to do now is
going to look at the parameters of this
Center word VC and work out how to do
things with respect to it now that's not
the only thing that you want to do you
also want to work out the slope with
respect to the uo vector
I'm not going to do that because time
and class is going to run out so it'd be
really good if you did that one at home
and then you'd feel much more confident
right so then I'm so what I'm wanting to
do is work out the partial derivative
with respect to my BC vector
representation of this quantity that we
were just looking at which is the
quantity in here where we're taking the
log of that quantity right the log of
the X of you Oh TVC over the sum that
we're equals 1 to be the X okay so this
so now we have a log of your division so
that's easy to rewrite that we have a
partial derivative of the log of the
numerator - and I can distribute the
partial derivative so I can have - the
partial derivative of the denominator
which is log of this thing okay so this
is sort of what was the numerator and
this is what was the denominator okay so
the part that was the numerator is
really easy in fact maybe I can fit it
in here so log and X are just inverses
of each other so they cancel out so
we've got the partial derivative of u OT
BC ok so at this point I should just
remind people right this VC here as a
vector of still a vectorized because we
had a hundred dimensional representation
of a word so this is doing multi-barrier
at calculus so you know if you're if
you're at all remember any of this stuff
you can say hi this is trivial the
answer that is you owe done and that's
great but you know if you're feeling not
so good on all of this stuff and you
want to sort of cheat a little on the
side and try and work out what it is you
can sort of say well let me work out the
partial derivative with respect to one
element of this vector like the first
element of this vector well what I've
actually got here for this dot product
is I have you O one times the C one plus
you owe two times B C 2 plus dot dot dot
plus you owe 100 times BC 100 right and
I'm finding the partial derivative of
this with respect to V c1 and hopefully
you remember that much calculus from
high school of none of these terms
involve vc-1 so the only thing that's
left is this you owe one and that's what
I've got there for this dimension so
this particular parameter but I don't
only want to do the first component of
the VC vector I also want to do the
second component the VC vector etc which
means I'm going to end up with all of
them turning up in precisely one of
these things and so the end result is I
get the vector u 0 ok but you know if
you're sort of getting confused and your
brain is falling apart I think it can be
sort of kind of useful to reduce things
to sort of single dimensional calculus
and actually sort of play out what's
actually happening anyway this part was
easy the numerator we get you O so
things aren't quite so nice when we do
the denominator so we now want to have
this D DBC
of the log of the sum of W equals 1 to V
of the expo view ot me see okay so now
at this point not quite so pretty we've
got this log sum X combination that you
see a lot and so at this point you have
to remember that there was use the chain
rule okay so what we can say is here's
you know our function f and here's the
body of the function and so what we want
to do is do it in two stages so that at
the end of the day we've got this VC at
the end so we have sort of some function
here there's ultimately a function of BC
and so we're going to do it with the
chain rule so the chain rule is we first
take the derivative of this outside
thing putting in this body and then we
remember that the derivative of log is 1
on X so we have 1 over the sum of W
equals 1 to V of the X both uo t vc and
then we need to multiply that by then
taking the derivative of the inside part
which is what we have here okay times
the derivative at the inside part with
the important reminder that you need to
do change of variables and for the
inside part use a different variable
that you're summing over okay so now
we're trying to find the derivative of a
sum of X and the first thing that we can
do is very easy we can move the
derivative inside a sum so we can
rewrite that and have it the sum first
of the x equals 1/2 V of the partial
derivatives with respect to VC of these
so that's a little bit of progress and
at that point we have to sort of do the
chain
all again right so here's our function
and here's the thing in it again which
is some function of VC so we again want
to do the chain rule and so we then have
well the derivative of X is X so we can
have the sum of x equals 1 to V of X of
UX TBC and then we're going to multiply
that by the partial derivative with
respect to D VC of the inside uxt VC
well we saw that one before so the
derivative of that is you well here you
X because we're doing it the different X
right so this then becomes out as UX and
so we have the sum of the x equals 1/2 V
of this x ux t BC times the U of X ok so
by doing the chain rule twice we've got
that and so now if we put it together
you know that our derivative of BC with
respect of the whole thing this log of
the probability of a given C right that
for the numerator it was just
UO and then we're subtracting we had
this term here which is sort of a
denominator and then we have this term
here which is a numerator so if we are
subtracting in the numerator we have the
sum of x equals 1 to B of the X of UX
TVC times UX and then in the denominator
we have the sum of W equals 1 to B of X
both UWT BC okay so we kind of get
oh wait yeah yeah that's right okay we
kind of get that and then we can sort of
just rearrange this a little so we can
have this sum right out front
and we can say that this is of our big
sum of X equals 1/2 V and we can sort of
take that UX at the end and say okay
let's call the put over here aux and if
we do that sort of an interesting thing
has happened because look we've right
here we've rediscovered exactly the same
form that we use as our probability
distribution for predicting the
probability of words so this is now
simply the probability of X given C
according to our model so we can rewrite
this and say that what we're getting is
uo- the sum of x equals 1 to V of the
probability of X given C times UX and
this has a kind of an interesting
meaning if you think about it
so so this is actually giving us you
know our slope in this multi-dimensional
space and how we're getting that slope
is we're taking the observed
representation of the context word and
we're subtracting from that what our
model thinks the context should look
like and what does the model think that
context should look like this part here
is formally an expectation so what
you're doing is you're finding the
weighted average of the models of the
representation of each word multiplied
by the probability of it in the current
model so this is sort of the expected
context word according to our current
model and so we're taking the difference
between the expected context word and
the actual context word that showed up
and that
difference then turns out to exactly
give us the slope as to which direction
we should be walking changing the words
representation in order to improve our
models ability to predict
okay so we'll assignment two if yeah so
it'd be a great exercise for you guys to
in to try and do that for the sent wait
I did the scent of words try and do it
for context words as well and show that
you can do the same kind of piece of
math and have it work out if I just got
a few minutes left at the end what I
just wanted to show you if I can get all
of this to work all right
okay okay so I just want to just show
you a quick example so for the first
assignment we're going it's an ipython
notebook so if you're all set up you
sort of can do Jupiter notebook and you
have some notebook here's my little
notebook I'm going to show you and the
trick will be to make this big enough
that people can see it
that readable okay
so right so so numpy is the sort of do
math package in Python you'll want to
know about that if you don't know about
it
matplotlib is sort of the one of the
most basic graphing package if you don't
know about that you're going to want to
know about it this is sort of an ipython
or Jupiter special and lets you have an
interactive map plot Lib inside and if
you want to get fancy you can play it
play with your graphic styles so there's
that scikit-learn is kind of a general
machine learning package gen sim
and sim is kind of a word similarity
package which started off with methods
like latent arisha analysis if you know
about that from modeling word
similarities there's sort of grown as a
good package for doing word vectors as
well so it's quite often used for word
vectors and word similarities it's sort
of efficient for doing things at large
scale yeah so I haven't yet told you
about will next time we have our own
homegrown form of word vectors which are
the glove word vectors I'm using them
not because it really matters for what
I'm showing but you know these vectors
are conveniently small it turns out that
the vectors that Facebook and Google
distribute extremely large vocabulary
and extremely high dimensional so it
take me just too long to load them in
the last five minutes of this class
we're conveniently in our Stanford
vectors we have a hundred dimensional
vectors and 50 dimensional vectors which
are kind of good for doing small things
on a laptop frankly um so what i'm doing
here is Jenson doesn't natively support
glove vectors but they actually provide
a utility that converts the glove file
format the word to vector file format so
I've done that and then I've loaded a
pre trained model of word vectors and so
this is what they call a keyed back
and so a keyed vector is nothing fancy
it's just you have words like potato and
there's a vector that hangs off each one
so it's really just sort of a big
dictionary with a vector for each thing
but so this model has been a train model
where we just used the kind of algorithm
we looked at and you know trained at
billions of times fiddling our word
vectors and once we have one we can then
ask questions like we can say what is
the most similar word some other words
so we could take something like what are
the most similar words to Obama let's
say and we get back Barack Bush Clinton
McCain Gore Hillary Dole Rotem Romney
Kerry that seems actually kind of
interesting these vectors are from a few
years ago so we don't have that post
post Obama staff I mean you can put in
an another word you know we can put in
something like banana and we get coconut
mango bananas potato pineapple we get
kind of tropical food so you can
actually you can actually ask it for
being dissimilar to words by itself
dissimilar isn't very useful so if I ask
most similar and I say negative equals
banana I'm not sure what your concept of
what's most dissimilar to banana is but
you know actually by itself you don't
get anything useful out of this because
you just sort of get these weird really
rare words which definitely weren't the
ones who are thinking of but it turns
out you can do something really useful
with this negative idea which was one of
the highly celebrated results of word
vectors when they first started off and
that was this idea that there is
actually dimensions of meaning in this
space and so this was the most
celebrated example which was look what
we could do is we could start with the
word
and subtract from at the meaning of man
and then we could add to it the meaning
of woman and then we could say which
word and our vector space is most
similar in meaning to that word and that
would be a way of sort of doing
analogies would be able to do the
analogy man is the king as a woman is to
what and so the way we're going to do
that is to say we want to be similar to
king and woman because they're both
positive ones and far away from man and
so we could do that manually
here's said manually most similar
positive woman King negative man and we
can run this and lo and behold it
produces Queen to make that a little bit
easier I defined this analogy analogy
predicate so I can run other ones and so
I can run another one like analogy
Japanese Japan Japanese Austria is too
Austrian and you know I think it's fair
to say that when people first saw that
you could have this simple piece of math
and run it and learn meanings of words I
mean it actually just sort of blew
people's minds how effective this was
you know like there are there's no
mirrors and strings here right you know
it's not that I have a separate a
special was sort of list in my Python
where there's a dick that I'm looking up
for austria austrian and things like
that but somehow these vector
representations are such that it is
actually encoding these semantic
relationships you know so you can try
different ones you know like it's not
that only this one works I can put in
France it since French I can put in
Germany it says German I can put in a
stray oh yeah not Austria and it says
Australian you know that somehow it's
weren't this vector representation of
words that the sort of these ideas like
understanding the relationships between
words you're just doing this vector
space manipulation on these hundred
dimensional numbers that it actually no
about them this not only the
similarities of word meanings but
actually different semantic
relationships between words like country
names and their people's and you know
that's actually pretty amazing and we'll
you know it's sort of surprising that
running such a dumb algorithm on vectors
of numbers could capture so well but
what meaning of words and so that sort
of became the foundation of a lot of
sort of modern distributed neural
representations of words okay I'll stop
there thanks a lot guys and see you on
Thursday